you i had ronnie cycly bro
yeah
is a legend in uh uh greece in lebanon
in lebanon he's a legend ronnie cycling
and in south africa
didn't he have like one big dunk fyi
the audience hates it when we talk about
sports and when we open up with sports
okay so today we're doing a two-hour
session just on sports but we're kidding
with you anyways i wish you guys were on
with us uh uh when we were having a
discussion um
gerrard thinks that should be a topic of
discussion on the podcast we started off
with
you know i'm sitting here with two
single men i'm married so the discussion
was
which country produces the most
beautiful women it's a matter of global
importance what i think is i think the
most beautiful women are produced in la
porte texas but outside of that if you
want to have the discussion
that's where your wife is from because
my wife is from la la port high school
yes so what do you think i got to tell
you man i think it's absolutely neck and
neck between venezuela and colombia man
like it's i and you know what i i think
uh thanks to the wonders of congress
venezuela on colombia thanks to the
wonders of communism colombia might have
pulled ahead in the last 10 years
because you know
eating dogs are bad luck now here's the
thing both of you guys have some
experience you played baseball and you
traveled which means you were i can
already see you being like you know a
guy that got around and adam
you know your mom and i had a great
conversation yesterday okay yeah you
know she was encouraging me to
uh uh you know like have some positive
influence on you i promise you behind
closed doors you're an incredible rabbi
you just don't want to tell her you're a
rabbi
what do you think most beautiful woman
in the world well i think there's two
ways we can go here we go by the way
everybody's listening what do you think
i'm actually curious we're looking at
the comments i think
uh yeah i would love to hear the
comments number one somebody said a
syrian that's actually not better
syrians make beautiful there's two ways
to look at this i think
yeah i'm not going to give you the
outside beauty inner beauty i'm just
going to give you you know there is no
such thing as inner beauty because it
was a beauty if there was an outside
beauty when you speak like that you're
looking for a wife so wait he's
transitioning got respect here's the
deal inner
with your
small head gerard
you just go with your eyes only eyes
only and maybe you're right with
columbus you're about to go in the right
direction
but go ahead i'm a huge fan of banter
okay banter yeah so i like american
women i like banter like we're talking
about subject ding ding ding ding ding
we got it i've been like i've been out
with adam a bunch and it's it's
incredible that the women who must have
the most uh incredible banter all are
right
maybe that's why you've only seen me out
with them once or twice because the
banter wasn't that good and we had to
move on okay but i've heard so you're
saying american i love american well
what what prompted this is is my buddy
jason fox who was here over the weekend
was telling me that the best guy by the
way good dude man yeah the best place
he'd ever been in the world he said was
croatia and that was the second time i'd
ever heard that my buddy chris john
who's albanian how many countries have
you been to how many countries have you
been to i've been to i've been to canada
mexico you know you've never been
nowhere if you start off with i've been
to canada like i've only been i've only
been oh no colombia i've been and that's
it so i've only been in north america
central america and uh the caribbean and
and the the north of south america so i
not left the western hemisphere no i'd
love to go to i was supposed to go to
europe uh last year but i got two years
ago but i got i got i had other plans
unfortunately right so usually irish
women are not in your tops so
you irish are known for being tough and
and being uh smart and being uh
funny and good at banter i got
argentina colombia philippines sweden or
lebanon
russia russia you got to make an
argument for russia
uh albania assyrians uh brazil
uh chicago another assyrian chicago
actually low-key beautiful women by the
way three people said assyrian so at
this point the poll is overwhelming
i think the most beautiful women are
uh let me do the math here 25 assyrian
25 armenian father born and raised in
iran mom white from texas 80 british i
think that's the best combination her
name is senna i was going to say that it
sounds like santa
sent him brooklyn she is turning into a
beautiful girl senna has some
personalities
your facebook lives with her last series
so what car you want to buy
on a ferrari what color pink
so you want to buy pink rainbow i said
who's going to buy it for you you
why i don't have any money
so cute save that money
and we said russian by the way i know
we're going to move on i feel like
russian you're either like a five foot
eleven supermodel or you're like a
babushka grandma they don't speak the
the gupta but they're great at banter
but so who cares for you because you
like bands you give me the five foot
eleven that's got a good banter
by the way if you get the 511 supermodel
who's strong that can put you in your
place it may be an interesting
relationship right there all of a sudden
you see can you imagine adam starts
dating a girl every time you go out
adam's very quiet you go to dinner come
on i'm not saying anything she says say
say something say something adam's just
quiet hi how are you dear can i get you
something
i can see that happening i told you not
to talk yeah yeah why tell you sorry boy
you've been to a lot of different
countries yeah you've been to how many
i've been in australia i've been to
south america yeah i've been all over
united states beauty not not for
relationship just pure looks what was
what was the most beautiful woman you
saw where
just on i would say i was in mykonos
greece and that was pretty ridiculous
over there greece
yeah yeah yeah i think croatia is at the
top of the line i got an idea gerard and
i hit the scene we go all over europe we
do some man on the streets
zach in there as well you guys going to
do some anti-communist baseball
stressful jobs too stressful
to make sure as well
i worry about you guys kai's gonna be
very upset if we don't talk about the uh
i will say this the continent of the 48.
here we go i've been to 43 of the
continental 48. you've been to 43
continents yeah no no 43 of the
continent i've been to 43 continents
three planets all of it on mushrooms by
the way but the uh
the
best looking women i've seen in america
is south florida by far i think it's
pretty and then california is going to
come at me hard on this one but i think
south florida is i lived in california
24 years i'm still going to say south
well depends on your test taste south uh
florida is legit they can't compete
we're doing okay down here i think you
are yeah but everyone up here who's
watching this your wife comes stay in
new york you want no part of this well
stay in new york charles barkley would
say the best looking women are out of
san antonio
you ever heard a story about that or no
you said i never liked playing at the
spurs no because it's the worst because
i could never party afterwards but he
goes a little bit more detail if you
want to find out if i can do your own
right
what's this color behind me i've never
seen this color is that a red light
behind me go on that again i've never
seen that red light legit
is that like a message are you sending a
message that we're more red than blue is
something going on we got a blue light
over here already okay all right so we
got a lot of stories to cover we got a
lot of stories to cover
uh one fauci said he thinks it's a good
idea to
have airlines mandate vaccination cards
the passport maybe we can talk i know
you got some stuff to say about that
maybe we'll talk about that
children speak to voice speakers more
than their grandparents it's insane
that's problematic
billionaire entrepreneur mark allure
wants to build a nation's first woke
city first woke city okay i'm curious to
know what time i already bought a ticket
i'm sure you have by the way they have
an invitation i have an invitation for
you amazon offers to pay college fees of
750 000 frontline u.s workers okay i
have an idea what would be better of
them doing that maybe a better idea for
them the working war in afghanistan
ready cost americans
taxpayers 300 million dollars a day for
20 years can you imagine like that
number you just kind of say it
300 million dollars a day for 20 years
with big bills yet to come
college students were chanting uh a
beautiful chant for joe
joe biden over the weekend that tells
you the audience of college football
what was the chant by the way it was uh
uh uh
love joe biden except with a different
four-letter word
good luck joe biden
i like your attitude i like your
attitude okay uh right now if you're in
portland uh one high recommendation for
you guys if something happens to you do
not call 9-1-1 because apparently it's
taken five minutes
for cops to show up in portland amid
staff shortages we'll talk about that as
well maybe this defund police idea
wasn't working janet yellen said to us
we don't have to worry about any kind of
debt or inflation or anything however
she warns of a possible october default
on u.s that's swollen by the pandemic
what happened in six months what
happened in six months new york hospital
to pause delivering babies after workers
quit over vaccine mandate okay
joe manchin again he ought to run for
office man i don't think he's going to
do it but i think if he ran for office
president i think he ought to i think he
already holds office you mean no no i
i'm sorry to run for presidents yes so
you want to run for president because i
think uh he'd be surprised on how many
people he'd get i mean if the options
are slim he may get a lot of people
there's something to be said about not
being an extremist on one side or the
other and just
kind of playing it safe well listen when
we were having dinner with uh
matt matt walton he said joe manchin is
pretty much a republican i don't know if
you remember that he said and you also
said that as well a little bit you said
joseph
i i'm a huge fan of joe manchin that's
kind of where i am politically
but so it is what it is so you got so
joe manchin said there's no way to pass
a a half million dollar budget by
september 27th reformed california
chairman on recall election obviously
the recallers i think today
with uh larry elder everybody encounters
i know we've got some very strong
feelings on then talk about we've had
meet kevin we've had major williams talk
about that uh it's a big deal two other
points we got the texas abortion law
creates a kind of bounty hunter we'll
talk about what the texas abortion law
because a lot of people are giving their
opinions on and last but not least we
had a pierce morgan commented on this we
have the article on it a uh uh he says
it made me sick to watch a once male
special forces combat veteran beat up a
woman on tv it's time to stop this trans
sport insanity before women start being
killed
and then a bunch of other things i don't
know if we're going to cover it but your
your friend conor mcgregor did another
mcgregor-esque thing let's talk about
that what do you think about that so
what do you know about what happened i
mean i'll read what the story tells us
there's multiple different uh versions
of it on page three
uh if you go to so they're at the show
right they're after this
mtv music awards conor mcgregor
reportedly tried to fight machine gun
kelly because mgk didn't want to take a
picture with them we know why connor is
angry at machine gun kelly on sunday
videos of conor mcgregor trying to
attack the rapper mg at the vma surface
on the internet uh sources connected to
the situation paid that connor asked mgk
for photo which kelly denied and that
apparently escalated into him push
encounter who stumbled back and spilled
his drink when he collected himself and
whatever was left of his drink connor
allegedly chucked the drink at kelly as
well as megan who was nearby their
perspective teams broke up broke it up
before things got ugly and kind of was
given his walk and came back something
that had fallen to the ground during the
scuffle thank god he got his came back
but thank goodness tell me what do you
think about what happened i think uh
just real quick uh this guy
machine gun kelly is dating
megan fox he is better than by the way
what country is she from america america
damn america take your russian [ __ ]
known megan fox is known for phenomenal
banter just so you know from the moment
i'm telling you again from the moment
her and shia labeouf were not in
transformers i was done yeah i went on
strike i said i'm done people don't know
this but in your top five actors of all
time shia labeouf is in it not top five
but i'm a die-hard child like listen i'm
also a die-hard edward norton fan i
think these two guys are legit but i'm
also i like a andy garcia i like some
strange actors i like john bernthal i
think john is a beast of an actor but
yeah i would say shy is up there for me
but go ahead so yeah all right so it was
the mtv music awards by the way do you
even watch that anymore no i don't watch
it at the mtv music
any awards anymore stop it you were
taking notes on your iphone i do watch
the clips of it afterwards to see what's
going on i think bieber one artist of
the year i don't watch it but i know
bieber one here we go i'm a bieber fan
all right i'm a beaver fan like you're a
shia labeouf fan but i also like bieber
i think bieber's a stad well let's name
three songs of bieber yeah i would have
to if you play i probably can name you
40 songs i don't know the name of the
songs okay but i like the one song he
did lately
about a year ago when he's sitting there
by himself singing about being lonely as
a kid performing nobody was back with
them that messaging i think it was
called lonely lonely it could have been
great there's two two versions of the
video is it too late to say i'm sorry
no i don't think it is okay i don't
think it is all right what do you mean
uh these are beaver songs anyway
i'm gonna be but anyway i think we're
gonna get to the bottom connor was there
to i think introduce the wind of the
song of the year anyway he was there
um
to introduce uh one of the categories
but he showed up and i think the story
here isn't machine gun kelly the only
reason the machine gun kelly is relevant
in my opinion is because he's dating
megan fox if he was just some dude that
was just this rapper i think he'd be
irrelevant that's not true though
the dude took uh he went from being a
rapper with beef with eminem to turning
into the lead singer of some 41 and
nobody even blinked an eye like he's
he's actually pretty the fact that he
has beef with eminem
it is laughable to me he's nowhere close
to being where the rap god lives
but that one song he put was pretty
legit the lyrics he put out that was
actually not bad machine gun kelly yes
never heard it i'm not a fan i don't
know it anyway i thought it was pretty
decent he hates the link i think the
story here is from croatia just saying
that no no okay it makes sense go ahead
i have no clue if he's crazy
no yeah he's from definitely america
but it is impressive how megyn kelly
hypes him up she calls her the most
beautiful boy and the most talented did
i say megan kelly i do love megan kelly
megan fox by the way machine gun kelly
megan fox just come out here's the story
guys
what's your point
i think connor is having a meltdown i
think connor he just needed to win he
needed a win
he could beat this skinny bean pole
rapper i think connor
is his best days are behind him he's
made his money you interviewed dustin
poirier and he said quote unquote it's
kind of hard to get up and put in the
work and run your miles when you're
sleeping in satin sheets something like
that yeah so i think conor's made his
money he's made his name he's turning
into more of a celebrity influencer he's
walking around with a cane well his foot
has fallen off i don't know if he's ever
gonna fight at the level that he was and
this is sort of like a pr stunt to keep
his name in the news that's my two cents
yeah i i haven't fought in five years
but even five years ago uh guys i was
fighting with that are really really big
names in the ufc guys i was in like
fight camps for and stuff like that they
would tell me
like dude never been on mcgregor ever
again like he he parties too hard he
goes way way too far
irish whiskey bro you know yeah yeah
basically blanton's at proper 12
the uh
but as as a guy who who drank way too
much whiskey and did too many dumb
things himself
until
you get to a certain age where you know
look the problem when you're a good
fighter and the problem when you're a
bigger dude even though conor's not but
he's very good fighting he's very tough
and you're a boozer and you're doing
whatever comes with the booze you're a
tornado of destruction nobody can stop
you see one of the big problems one of
the reasons i don't drink hard alcohol
anymore is because nobody could stop me
and i i was good at drinking so i
wouldn't black
i wouldn't black out so where most other
people would pass out or you know
somebody else would be able to grab them
and throw them in a car they couldn't do
that with me i was too big and i was too
violent and like i would just turn into
a non-stop life-destroying menace until
finally like it it slows down do you not
get the irony here you're wearing an
ireland green iron shirt
that's a whole drinking irish world
it would be like me saying a jewish guy
goes on on radio every day saying save
that money
it's true pat you've interviewed dustin
poirier i know you're a fan of
connor what's your take on all this i
don't know i think uh i think uh you
know if you if you look at it from
there's a few different ways to look at
it number one
it's very hard one of the hardest things
to do
is
when you're when you're
this happens to a lot of different
people but when you're
extremely attractive and all of a sudden
you get to an age and you're not getting
the attention you got psychologically
that messes with you women oh my gosh
that by the way it's torture
it's torture and that's why sometimes a
young boy can always you know sometimes
get together with a
older woman 45 50 because it's a
confirmation from the older woman to say
a 22 year old is still attracted to me
it's not coach and demi moore it's a
form of confirmation right by the way it
happens to everybody so that's one
example
this is paralleling tyson pretty tightly
though yeah yeah so so then by the way
even tyson talked about mcgregor tyson
talked about mcgregor in the interview
tyson's interview has got to be one of
my top five interviews of all time the
guy was hilarious by the way that the
plane reference was the funniest thing
he was just hilarious period yeah you
can't cancel me i got my own
so and then so so that's that's the
woman side right and then
for athletes you go from a lamar odom do
you kidding me you're a champion you're
a laker everybody's following you all of
a sudden
nobody like do you when's the last time
you googled lamar odom yeah he fought uh
aaron carter actually answered that
question when's the last time you
googled lamar odom he he got kardashian
and he got done right
so he stood up and chewed up and yeah on
the other side so but think about how
many times that happens to athletes it's
tough psychologically it's tough right
it happens to boxers it happens to
athletes and there's a part of it that i
think it's the fault of
the game it's the fault of the sport
it's the fault of somebody not shaping
the character of that becoming a reality
at dinner with a couple this week and
the incredible dinner we were at eddie
vs
uh uh
their uh three-year-old daughter died
they're on vacation they come back they
have no idea what's going on all of a
sudden their three-year-old
dies
by the way i mean you know we're talking
right nature went to a completely
different angle story-wise and he sits
there and i'm like
i couldn't even talk to an entire night
like to me my stomach hurt i would just
feel like i'm hearing this now i don't
even want to hear about it right but my
stomach hurts i'm like you know i can't
even eat the food we're ordering nice
food and it's like they're just sitting
there being very
you know christian family they're being
strong about it and they're like listen
it was very tough but we had to overcome
this and all this stuff
and and uh they said the one thing that
kids that parents don't do enough
talking to their kids about is the idea
of death this is because you don't even
think about it now that took me
immediately back when i was six years
old and we're getting bombed on and my
dad sat down and talked to me about
dying like what is the matter with this
guy he's saying one day i'm gonna die i
said you know you're not gonna die says
one day i'm gonna die says you have to
understand that
if i die you have to be happy i said why
do i have to be happy he said because
you had six years with your dad many
people don't even have a dad in their
lives i said you mean to tell me when
your mom dies you're not going to cry he
says no i'm thankful i've had my mom for
so many years i'm going to be happy with
the smile i said no you're not he says
watch me so his mom dies at 72 from
cancer
and i go and i see him because you know
as a kid as a boy i've been watching
this man for my entire life so i'm like
let me see let me see how much this
guy's going to be real with me or not
and i watch him he had a smile on his
face
your dad and he had a smile on his face
he's a nice guy he's freaking my dad he
had a smile on his face his eyes are
filled up and i'm looking at this guy
i'm like what a freaking man you are
right
and he's telling stories and he's saying
all these great things about you know my
mom this my mom and my mom this like you
got to freaking appreciate this guy so
there is lessons in
somebody like a dana sitting there
having the serious camera i think the
sports game got to do that i think
somebody's got to do that with women
with celebrities to say connor
here's where you are let me just kind of
paint this picture for you and you tell
me what you want to do you've lost three
matches alone in a row okay
you're now getting unnecessary attention
you don't need the last time you got
unnecessary attention like this is when
you threw that uh what do you call it in
the box right it wasn't a chair it was a
yeah what was it it was uh the bench and
he ended up that poor guy's career with
yeah yeah i mean it was like what are
you doing it for is it attention what do
you do and then you go and you come out
with your drink and you punch the guy in
the face at a bar oh dude and then later
on you buy that bar and oh dude didn't
even flinch by the way he just continued
right
so some of these meltdowns someone has
to have a serious conversation now
here's the other part
if he doesn't have if he doesn't receive
it the onus is all on who
on the individual yeah and then you got
to say look we have the conversation he
still chooses to live this life but i
think conor has an opportunity right now
because he's so
big right now with his name
if he figured out a way to transition
into another field if he if he was able
to do it look at daniel cormier if he
was able to do it the world forgets
about all the la look at how many times
cormier lost at the end cormier is done
he's a guy that's going to get that
respect he's just got to figure right
away to go there but i don't think the
kind of attention that he was getting
for that five year period seven year
period i don't think that's coming you
brought up a lot of amazing points pat
you know everything with your dad is
incredible um is emotional as
well something to be said about conor's
when you're winning
you can kind of get away with some of
the antics right some of it is
justifiable it's almost marketing pr but
when you're losing
it just seems sad desperate yeah and
desperate well there's two two parts of
that man well the first part is i've
talked to you about this i have a theory
and it's i think guys
do self-destructive things in these
positions because it's easier for for
someone like connor a high-level athlete
a high-level performer to say
oh man if i if i only didn't drink or oh
man if i only didn't do this or do that
i could have gotten my comeback and
they're looking for an excuse and yeah
they're giving themselves an out there's
a lot of guys i played with man there's
a lot of dudes that i feel like they did
these things because it's easier to be
seen as still having that potential as
potentially i still could have done it
if only i could have overcome these
demons as opposed to being like man i
just don't have it anymore or man i'm
just not good enough and i think that
that's that's part of this that's mental
health this is depression manifesto yeah
i don't i don't disagree here's the
other part that you have to be thinking
about when everybody was trashing tiger
i'd say do you even know what it is to
be the greatest
golfer in the world and you're black in
a white sport and you're crushing every
do you know what it feels like to be
that guy do you know what it is to be
the guy that from two years old
he was a guy that was going to be who he
was going to become and then his dad
said and then he becomes that guy do you
know what it is to be person how many
people in the world have that kind of
story outside of lebron james maybe even
lebron james's father wasn't in a
picture so so the point is unless we
know
what it's like to be the guy that you
get on a fight
hundreds of millions of people want to
find out what the hell is going to
happen no one's going to understand it
so there's a part of it that conor is
going to say who the hell are you guys
to even know what i'm going through
right sure it's always easier to give
advice from the outside so that's the
other thing that we need to also
consider because we have no idea what it
is to be the face of ufc for five seven
years bill barr with one of the greatest
kids of all time about that like oh yeah
oh you if you were in tigers position
you would have gone over there
yeah like like you've got a bus full of
swedish norwegian supermodels
mercury tracer to use your point right
there there's something to be said about
being married in that position versus
being single in that position yeah i
feel like for conor being married is
probably a blessing for him stability
family to be single to be this wild
crazy fighter who likes to drink that
marriage only matters
by the way by the way i tell you what he
may be he may be doing tyson was married
too
but here's the difference he may be
doing stuff behind closers i don't know
i don't speculate because that's not my
world i'm not in it and people can say
whatever they want to say they can make
it about anybody
we got to give him credit his wife is
everywhere with him no matter where he
goes she's right next to him right so
there is a part of it where it's kind of
like look salute he puts the pictures
you know he puts stuff from his family
it's not like he's hiding it some guys
don't want to show that he's kind of
doing his part so who knows we'll see
what's going to happen but is she being
that that stabilizing force or is this a
bonnie and clyde situation i don't know
we'll never know that i will tell you
this here's what i'm hoping
i am hoping he makes a comeback he has a
big victory and then
he says here's what i'm doing but i
don't see that happening because today's
model of boxing he's going to go
probably fight jake because he's going
to make 30 million bucks on it he's
going to go find logan 50 million
dollars i want him in the booth so bad i
i want conor mcgregor sitting next to
joe rogan talking about mcgregor you can
snoop in the booth
yeah that would be that's the show okay
yeah you guys only spent 30 minutes on
condor just so you know that wasn't
supposed to be the story to appreciate
we actually went deep on it yeah that
was impressive yeah that's a good
dialogue that's by the way did you see
aoc goes to a dinner that's 30 to 35
thousand dollars ahead of you
and she wears a dress
she wears a dress saying tax the rich
after partying
with the rich she wears this dress
that's a thousand bucks hanging out with
millionaires and billionaires and she
sports this dress saying tax the rich
and people go
bonkers over it what uh what a
noble uh human being she is is it
hypocrisy what is the word for this
stupidity no first of all i will tell
you what it is number one is genius
marketing okay for her for her i
actually agree i i think it's genius
marketing she's she's a genius when it
comes down to marketing i don't care
what anybody says they're pissed off
because she comes up with these ideas in
the area of marketing you couldn't have
thought about a you couldn't have had a
better person a better marketer for the
message of socialism you couldn't have a
better marketer a rich girl who
chose to vacation in poverty and gives a
story about i couldn't pay my bills well
because i was bartending in new york
first of all anybody knows anybody who
bartends in new york they make cake all
right that's number one number two yeah
they spend it all on rent so it's not
like they're right it's like their net
worth is that rent rent and other things
but the
she couldn't afford
right to live her life because this is
the part of the story that nobody ever
talks about she was spending all day
volunteering on the bernie sanders
campaign
she was she was an unpaid employee for
bernie sanders so she's telling
capitalism is the worst i had to work
and i was i was overqualified and
underpaid because bernie sanders didn't
pay her well enough
she wants to talk like she's jenny from
the blocks jenny from westchester she
went to bu
dude stop it with this we gotta i as a
as a people as a globe we have to be
able to look at something and say this
is by sooner this is pure trash enough
of this already
tax the rich 3 500 she spent five
thousand thousand thirty five thousand
dollars who's 75 per table let me say
this again it's thirty five thousand
dollars a person thirty to thirty five
thousand each table was actually seventy
five but but people that are richer than
me i'm not rich i'm just i'm just i'm
done don't be don't be don't be fooled
by the rocks that i got i'm just aoc
from here here's the question she shows
up there's you know probably a couple
thousand people here
what's the
what's the story line when she shows up
are people shaking her hand are they
giving her a hug give her a kiss is the
is she is she a rock star there do they
hate her is she sitting in the corner
are people being like we love you like
what's the oh i think what's the
scenario i think those who are holding
up to messaging of uh democrats they
have to agree with her whether they they
like it or not because they're worried
about being canceled oh my god you're
throwing right here
the fear
the fear of being cancer because here's
how you got to do it so what's what's
more expensive
50 taxes or
losing those three movies what's more
expensive the movie yeah who gives a
[ __ ] about fifty percent i can't lose
that movie at twenty million dollars a
pop ten million dollars a pop so i'm
like listen you're amazing you're
amazing but it's a form of control
it is a form of cancer culture the fear
in actors hollywood they're so worried
about it very few of them are willing to
come out and say this woman's lost her
freaking
mind because if they do that they can
potentially lose the next job that's
coming out in hollywood everyone in
hollywood is afraid right now except for
some of the guys that are stepping away
saying look we don't give a [ __ ] what
you're gonna be doing we're gonna do our
own thing we don't need you guys anymore
we're gonna do our own thing yeah i
think there's a coup going on in
hollywood as well low key you've got
bernie sanders all right bernie sanders
not one not two but three houses makes a
million dollars
he donates less than one percent of that
less than one percent he donates when he
somebody the one journalist left in
america asked him the questions like so
what would you say to people who who
are are
you know claiming hypocrisy with your
crusade against the rich when you are in
fact rich well
if they wanted to be rich they should
they should have wrote a book like oh
okay that's that's the answer how much
money has she made off this tax to rich
merch she is the most capitalist in in
dc she's got an entire tax great
marketer and i'm going to tell you
what's going to make a hell of a cmo
this is the truth hell of a cmo do you
see this right by the way we'd hire her
right now if she could set aside her
socialistic tendencies with her right
now you see this right here this is the
crux of all the issues gentlemen this
right here she's a latina from the bronx
ain't got no booty that is the that's
what's happening here she needs to she
wants to
she needs to redistribute she saw look
if anybody's ever been in a bx anybody's
ever been uptown there we go you get it
you just got personal bro you got a
dominican or a puerto rican girl they
walk in hips first everywhere they go
she got upset she's mad she's mad this
this is why she she was the level of
mother you don't talk about he went
through he went there
without a booty he went there back by
the bro you know it's funny you bring up
the bernie sanders thing and i'm not a
fan of bernie but i will say this if
you're freaking 80 years old and you've
been making i don't know what do you get
paid 180 grand a year and you're still
and you don't have any money you know of
a house
he's never had a real job but he's only
ever worked off of the government dole
regardless that's his job he's a
parasite whatever he is the point is
this if you're 80 years old and you're
still broke that's probably a bigger
problem at least this guy's broke he's
not that's my point he's like to have a
house and to be a millionaire at age 80
is not that big of an accomplishment
congratulations you've
saved ten percent of your income and i
tell you this you get your benefits
it's not that big of a deal she has a 10
to 20 chance of being a president in the
next 20 years remember when i said this
what are the
chances gets gerard's vote
dude the green new deal it's gonna it's
gonna pass yeah like she's winning she's
got ten to twenty percent aoc antoinette
let them eat brunch she doesn't need our
vote by the time by the time she becomes
a good president
yeah so let's go to this mark lore story
billionaire entrepreneur mark lohr wants
to build the nation's first woke city i
actually want to know what this looks
like so can you actually pull up the
article to see if they show any images
on there it's about 60 years so a former
walmart executive an e-commerce
billionaire mark lure wants to build the
world's first woke city from scratch
somewhere in the us we are going to be
the most open the most fair and the most
inclusive city in the world laura said
in a promotional video the city is meant
to take on what lore's view on the
united states the biggest challenge the
rapidly grown wealth gap which he said
is growing going to bring down america
the initial phase of the project
targeted for completion by 2030 would be
built to accommodate 50 000 residents
across 1500 acres at a cost of 25
billion over 40 years the city will
eventually
require 40 400 billion dollars of
funding and funding and grow to house as
many as 5 million people across 150 000
acres if it's so effective why do you
need to be funded
why do you need to be funded to build
this woke city that's what it's going to
look like by the way take a look at that
wow
what a beautiful woke city that is that
needs funding from other taxpayers who
are not woke so the only way a woke city
model works that it's funded by people
who are not welcome really i love when
the uh the 17 year old communist always
talks about how the only reason why cuba
was unsuccessful was because of the evil
embargoes from the united states like
whoa whoa this this this communist
utopia needed their capitalist neighbor
what would you not making the argument
you think you're making here man
have they said what state this would be
in
uh i would imagine oregon next to
portland can you actually go to the
article to see what they're thinking
about city-wise
as long as it's not in florida and texas
if we should be fine we just
don't want to go i'm i'm looking to it's
called telos
is that a play on tesla
called telosa tulosa from the ancient
greece
telos meaning highest purpose the
mission of telos is to create more
equitable sustainable future that's our
north star we're going to be the most
open okay i read that equitism equitism
equitism
residents in turn own their own homes on
the land and are enriched as home value
increases according to the project site
and after period of hyper growth
residents can buy the land from the
community endowment
okay if you went into the desert where
the land wasn't numbers
and foundation okay we don't know well i
folks if you're listening to this
anybody planning on going to this woke
city it sounds like burning man
that's what that sounds what it sounds
like is you're gonna get a mortgage from
the city instead of a bank it sounds
exactly like what we have now except
your mortgages to the city instead of
the bank these guys have lost their mind
by the way to do something like this by
the way here's here's what i'm willing
to do why don't we do this see that hold
on real quick you see that stuff i don't
mind like when they start talking about
new york city you know every rooftop in
new york city should be solar or you
should have plants on it i'm totally
okay there's only one problem i have
with this there's only one problem i
have with this i actually say go do it
matter of fact here's what i think we
ought to do
you go do yours let us go build our own
city let us build our own city you go
build your own let's make it a project
let us go 20 years sure we build our own
city give us 1500 acres you get 1500
acres we get 1500 we get 49 states you
guys get california if communism works
in 20 years i'm actually being dead
serious if we got 1500 acres we got our
own land that we would build
they get their own 1500 acres
here's the difference here's the
difference there's only one caveat here
one caveat there can be zero funding
from the government
zero funding from taxpayers you do your
work city we do all our own free thinker
city let's see 20 years what happens
okay let's just say 20 years what
happens
neither can we can do whatever we can do
20 years later let's see what we produce
let's see what you produce a city full
of people let's see what kind of people
we produce and let's see what kind of
people are you going to produce
and who ends up recruiting who from
which city your woke city versus the
free thinker city you know there was a
movie that this reminds me of uh one of
my favorite actors is leonardo dicaprio
and i don't know ten plus years ago he
did a movie called the beach yeah which
was supposed to be like this um
this paradise i think i think it took
place in thailand i want to say he was
googling paradise
and he shows up him and a friend and
another girl and they go to this city
and it's this paradise and it's
you know egalitarian and everything's
beautiful and the most
pristine beaches in the world and you're
hunting and killing and finding your own
food and then it takes a very ugly turn
and where
human nature yeah human nature kicks in
and um
what's the uh what's the movie where the
the kids they're all on the island and
they they kill the fat kid because he
that they speak with a conch what was
that movie what was the book uh oh i
know what's talking about you talking
about lord of the flies lord of the
flies yeah very lord of the fly-esque
type of situation the bottom line is it
starts off in this
paradise type
uh
story and it looked amazing and by the
end of the movie everyone was freaking
dead and the guys came in and killed
everybody that's what's going to happen
with this woman it's very the only way
communism will ever work the only way
communism will ever work two things have
to happen they have to take over the
entire world they have to have control
of all access to opportunity worldwide
and two they have to do
uh set marriages from the time you're
born lottery marriages because
everything literally everything that we
do everything that our species has ever
done has been a competition for ovaries
that is what it is everything from helen
of troy helen of troy decided to go with
a younger better looking pritz and the
king of macedonia said screw that and
brought a million troops over to troy
and 20 years and then it's in the brad
pitt movie orlando broome
it's a little bit of an older book but
yeah so yeah you know it was the movie
was called troy i get it i know it's the
iliad of the odyssey
but yeah
but listen literally think about it
everything we do why do you work so hard
you work so hard to provide for your
family you why do you work out i have
been very in very good shape with abs i
have been very very fat i'm getting back
down again do you know why
because there's benefits to being in
better shape you have to say everything
that we do as men yeah everything we're
90 of us there's 10 that don't play that
game but 90 of men everything that we do
is to attract the other species if you
aren't gonna be born six foot nine 275
pounds then you have to figure out a way
warren buffett said it best warren
buffett when he talks about taxes and
why he wants to give back he's like
because i am very very lucky
that i grew up in a time where my
intellect allowed me to
generate wealth because if the only way
i could generate wealth was getting on a
boat and storming the seas i wouldn't
have been very wealthy i'd been very
dead so that's his idea of giving back
right
everything that we do everything
capitalism really is is fair good for
him by the way yeah good morning
it is a fair place system to be able to
i'm telling you listen give us 1500
acres i'm telling you right now
if we got a million people
in in a small little country
test it out with us give us for 20 give
us 20 or see what we do
the world would want to live in our
country yeah okay it would be called
america give it but here's the thing
america is no longer america
america unfortunately is going in in a
different direction
the ideas but there are a few things at
the beginning as a case study that
america could have done slightly
differently what do you mean america is
no longer america you can't just say
that and then we never gloss over no no
no what are you talking about america's
still america america is still the
greatest country in the world but
america is no longer the america that
the america is not the america that i
came to america for lots changed last 30
years a lot's changed the last 30
minutes changed the last 18 months yeah
a lot's changed this is a
do you realize i don't know if i don't
know if you really realize this
if i told you 10 years ago
the president's gonna say
i'm sick and tired i'm losing patience
with these governors
who are not mandating vaccine and who
are not getting their people to get
vaccinated
if if i told you 10 years ago this isn't
about you in about 10 years in 2021
a guy's going to come out with named
tony okay
who's in his 80s who's gonna say
we have to mandate vaccine if i told you
20 years ago nicki minaj decides to not
go to an award ceremony
because she says a one of her friends
from trinidad one of her relatives in
trinidad got a vaccine and you know
afterwards they couldn't have a kid
because something happened anyways she
says that she says i'm worried i'm doing
my research but i'm getting closer to
feeling confident to take the vaccine
i'm willing to do my own research and
she decides not to go to awards ceremony
because they wanted people to be mad
vaccinated then a lady from cnn cnbc i
don't know which one it was msnbc she
says you have a lot of followers it's a
shame you have 22 million followers i
have 2 million followers shame on you
for using twitter to tell people that
you could have done something about this
yet people are dying
if i told you 10 years ago how dare you
be your own person but if i told you 10
years ago that the idea of choices
is going away would you have said that's
possible would you have said that's
going to happen to america the idea of
having a choice is yeah i see what
you're saying right there so that's the
whole point is having the option or
having the choice bro like the biggest
nobody likes mandates
let me ask you a question but at the
same time you can't just say i have the
choice to run the red light i do what i
want it's like no there's laws but you
do have the choice
right exactly i mean then you go to jail
or your car car story
i'll pay the ticket
it's a story in my life my license got
suspended twice it's my choice that's
fine right i have a choice
certain areas yes but for me to have to
put something in my body that's not my
choice i'm with you you should have the
choice
yes the other part of medicine you know
yes yes yes
i'm talking to i'm talking to a guy
named michael shermer i don't know if
you know who michael shermer is michael
sherman's got a he wrote that book said
uh weird things what's the book called
something about weird things anyways
very interesting guy he went from being
a christian to being an atheist to being
an agnostic okay the guy's got uh great
ideas on what he talks but he pushes
everything back christianity we had a
very strong debate yesterday he says you
know what's crazy he says for about a
year and a half you couldn't question
the fact that the covenant may have come
from china until it took a comedian to
go on stephen colbert to talk about it
where the world finally said johnson we
can talk about it john cena how is that
even possible so freedom of speech in
the last 24 months very weird choice
very weird these are real fundamental
stuff that makes america great
these are the things that have changed
and uh there's a part of it where you're
worried whether people are willing to
fight back or just sit there because
at the end of the day what's the first
thing people think think about how do
they make their decisions they make
their decisions with what what's the
best for their family and themselves
right typically what's in it for them so
why do you think this whole idea of tax
the rich is so popular because 90
percent of country is not rich
i don't give a [ __ ] go rich go tax
everybody right but 30 years ago the
whole idea was what man one day i'd love
to be what rich
it was the story of the life of the rich
and famous people aspired to it was like
let me go one day get this kind of a
lifestyle let me one day go to a party
like this do wait today's the other way
around do you think people really think
3.5 trillion dollars in taxes are about
to be levied against the the american
public and it's only going to be the
rich i got a caller
seriously no it's going to destroy
everybody a small a small business
that's making a half a million dollars a
year you saw kudlow talk about it small
business that's making half a million
dollars a year
you know what it means to increase their
tax capital gains by the way they're
already talking about they're going to
back data to yesterday
like this morning i was talking to
greg they're talking about they can back
date capital gains to yesterday
top line taxes they're raising to 39.6
they're adding an additional three
percent for people that make over five
million a year and then on top of that
the small business taxes that's also
being risen
uh by i think it's like six and a half
percent some number like that six
percent they're increasing it um but
this is just a proposal this is nowhere
near passing not it's no longer just a
proposal now it's getting to a point
that it could be passed before 1-1 the
only thing that's stopping it is joe
manchin joe manchin is the only thing
he's literally the only person again
he's he's literally the only person
that's known so when you ask me about
america a lot's changed the last 20.
people that think that this is only
going to be the rich
need to look at one thing all right i
sent you guys this last night biden
directed the treasury his treasury in
the irs to start tracking all
transactions for bank accounts as low as
meaning if you put a hundred dollars in
to dogecoin and it and it's 6x you've
got 600.
no it's for everything but but it's also
tracking crypto for the first time you
put a hundred dollars into whatever to
dogecoin you hit the lotto 600 bucks you
pulled it out all right they're gonna
come at you for 150 bucks you made a
hundred dollar investment you 6x
congratulations kid you're you're an 18
year old they're gonna want a hundred
and fifty dollars in taxes on that and
then back to back pay like they're
they're coming so people that think that
this is only you know a soak the rich
type of a situation bro they're tracking
you down to
600.00 by the way listeners i got a
question for you
to you define rich what is rich to you
i'm curious
actually put a number to it okay like
you know how they say this person's tall
what would you say is tall
what height would you say is tall
depends on where you are but playing
ball like really um what's tall in
america well this is the thing so you
know when hillary clinton was coming out
with this whole if you're uh a dual
family yeah in america and you make a
combined 100 000 you're wealthy this was
like eight years ago i remember being i
was playing ball in iowa at the time and
i was like you know what 100 000 in
highway you're pretty rich 100 000
dollars in north jersey you're just
paying the bills what would you say is
tall what's tall on the market i get
what you're saying is that there's no
exact answer is there is there is six
feet
then you could say ten is tall i think
six is tall i don't think six is tall i
think quarters above 510 is the average
mills height in america five nine five
ten five nine five okay six is tall i'd
say anything over six three is tall i
don't i think you're six that's what
you're saying because you are six i
think six is tall but but here's the
thing what is rich i'm actually curious
what people say here uh a million
dollars is rich ten million dollars is
rich five million dollars is rich
hundred million dollars at least daniel
says 10 million in assets over a million
dollars says
valeria uh uh
over a million dollars okay augustine
says five million dollars so if you have
a million dollars what is that that's 50
000 a year for 20 years that that's what
you're but here's the point though corey
mcdonald mcdougall says three hundred
thousand dollars ethan eats says thirty
five thousand dollars ricky aguirre says
five hundred thousand dollars yeah
no not ricky aguilar ricky aguirre ricky
aguirre says five hundred thousand
dollars here's the point who the hell
decides what's rich okay because to me
aoc when i was working at bally's aoc is
rich
are you kidding me because
when i worked at valleys the guy i was
looking up to was a guy named robbie
solomon
he had been at valleys for nearly 20
years he was an area supervisor
something everyone aspired to be guess
what he was making
150 year after 20 years and the pitch
was patrick one day you can be an area
supervisor
one day you can meet every supervisor
making 150 a year and i'm sitting i'm
like wow 150 freaking a year are you
kidding me this is insane if i make that
kind of money because i was making 36.
right 150 is a lot of money but you know
what it is when you make 150 it ain't a
lot of money so what is rich and who
defines what's rich
what what a global scale everybody in
america is everybody in america is rich
right right global scale but but the
challenge with that is a politician
dictates what's rich a politician
dictates like upon to me the average
person i'm sorry nancy pelosi is super
rich elizabeth warren rich
you got
bernie sanders super rich you got a aoc
rich you got a lot of people that are
rich so who dictates what that number is
is it like you know how you said you're
six feet i think six two is tall
it's the same exact concept right it's
what they say exact answer no no no it's
always more than what you have that's
the problem you just nailed it what you
did is what they do with taxes it's
always a little bit more than what you
are you natural i ask you what's tall
you said what six two i don't think six
is telling like what are you talking
about guys like five nine and a half
five ten he say what no i think six two
still said no six is tall right to them
they say no oh
elizabeth warren i'm worth 5 million 20
million dollars is rich then nancy
pelosi makes a phone call to elizabeth
warren hey uh elizabeth you come from 20
million dollars i'm like i'm worth 50.
why don't we do 75. 75 million
what the hell is rich anything above you
is rich you make 2 million 5 million is
rich so this is a bunch of [ __ ] with
this whole concept of taxing the rich
anything above them that they don't have
to pay the price let's tax those guys
it's a really good point you don't run a
business you don't you're not affected
by capital gains screw the guys that get
capital gains affect those guys you're
not affected by running a business
hiring people raising the minimum wage
who gives a [ __ ] raise minimum wage it's
okay we're not affected by it
let's raise a federal minimum wage to 15
bucks in dc 15 bucks is nothing but in
iowa 15 bucks minimum wage is a lot of
money that small business owner got
crushed by walmart that's the stuff that
a lot of everything you're saying are
there progressives over there i call
them over there everything you're saying
it can be
applied to any topic
the money thing uh
abortion taxes you're talking about
schools
uh guns the bible everything as long as
it's
what they're doing and it's not me it's
it doesn't affect me
like
what's going on in texas right now with
abortions oh no you shouldn't be able to
have abortion in six weeks it's like
well what happened to the lady that was
raped by her uncle and just incest in
texas and she founds out you know two
months after
she she has no say in this so it's
always something that doesn't happen to
you and something happens to everybody
what is that called well you guys are
what is that what you guys are
discussing is the very basis of my
worldview why
why i believe the way i believe right
and i'm a libertarian most of the way
except i don't believe in the
non-aggression principle right but
there is no way
there is no way to centralize
government there's no way to take every
single aspect of our society and filter
it through the minds of these geniuses
which is what we're experiencing is is
an educational narcissism the likes of
which we've never seen we have an entire
system of people who went to school and
then they went to college and then they
went to law school and then they became
lawyers and then they got elected and
they they're in this cycle can you pull
up abortion what percentage of abortions
are rape
so they got they get into this cycle
where everybody throughout their whole
life has told them they're smart and
they're special so now they think that
they're so smart and so special that no
matter how many times centralization has
failed they're gonna be the ones that
figured it out they're gonna be the ones
that get it right this time i don't
believe that they can i think there's
too many variables at play so what i
believe in is
you do you and i'll do me do no harm if
it doesn't affect me you're welcome to
do it if you think that there is a real
problem with income inequality in the
world help the poor
don't steal from your neighbor and then
give somebody else money oh by the way
take a couple bucks for yourself for the
effort right and say that you're doing
something virtuous you're not virtuous
at that point
right so
anybody who wants to do anything i'm the
biggest advocate for charity i'm the
biggest advocate for for volunteerism
anything that you want to do advocate
for it but stop short of mandating it
stop short of making it a law
libertarian that's it yeah here look
look at this usa today just one percent
of women obtain an abortion because they
became pregnant through rape but less
than half a percent do because of incest
according to the gut okay institute yet
the battle over exceptions for both has
garnered outside attention national
abortion debate interesting so one
percent is
rape a half a percent is incest so
uh uh in the topic of rape you kind of
brought that up but in this specific
topic we're taxing the rich and the
topic of tax and direction people say
pat you're rich i don't dispute it i
don't say i'm not that's also one
percent but what i'm saying is i don't
dispute it but here's a different part
so i'm looking at the commentary one
guy's like hey pat just say it you're
rich i'm like who's who's debating that
i'm not who's not debating that
here's the debate the debate is the
following
the debate is this guy came from a
broken family divorced my out was the
army because i had a 1.8 gpa so jesus
guerra came and recruited me and i was
not a good athlete so i can't get a
full-ride scholarship because i never
disciplined myself to play sports even
though i was in shape even though i was
tall right so i go into the army i'm
going to do 20 years then i go into 20
years i get a phone call a guy
challenges me named kogan says i think
you can do more when you get out of the
army i said dude i'm not getting out i'm
re-enlisting tomorrow he calls me at
midnight coconut one of my best friends
in the world sweetest guy you've never
met him you'll meet him you'll love this
guy
so
i go to sleep try to go to sleep i wake
up in the morning go to lieutenant
colonel peacocks and i say listen i'm
gonna get out of the army because i'm
gonna go pursue my dreams but thank you
for everything you got me everything he
got that i wanted on my orders he got me
till today i'm looking for lieutenant
colonel peacocks he probably ended up
being a general because a guy was a g
was a leader
i get out i struggle
first business fails second business
fails i tried a personal profit portal
internet sale fails all these things i
do fails i'm working at valleys i quit
my job to try to do a business i'm gonna
get forty nine thousand dollars i go
back to recruiting to say if i go back
into the army what would i get
negotiations come in because there's a
part of it that can pay off your debt if
you sign in before six eight years i'm
like that's great i'll go back into the
army
then
i get this one message saying hang in
there see what happens a little bit
longer hang in there a little bit longer
hang in there a little bit longer i hang
in there i applied to get a job at
morgan stanley dean would i apply to 100
different places i was hustling to get a
resume in i eventually got the job they
offered me three jobs i went in without
a four-year degree two-year degree i
hadn't taken a test for three years
because i four years i've gone out i
don't know what it is to take a test for
four years right my brain's not been
working with us my brain's been working
with push-ups pull-ups you know all that
stuff
i go take the series 7 exam i'm studying
day and night i don't know if i'm going
to pass this i'm taking a test i press
that button you don't know what's going
to happen morgan fires if you don't pass
the test and when i'm pressing it i said
if i fail i'm re-enlisting to the army
today i swear to god and i press boom
30-second pause it's a six-hour test
dude i can't even tell you what my exam
was in culver city at the how old were
you with this 21 22 years old wow
i take the test december 12th of 01 so a
couple months after 9 11. result shows
up 78 i said no freaking way 78
[ __ ] i get to keep my job
so i go back and i show to morgan look
you got 70 outside i got 78
damn none of us thought you're going to
get i said dude
so then i stay i work my ass off my dad
has a heart attack rather than partying
five days a week i put my head into the
books and i started reading a girl the
other night we're having dinner and
everybody's talking about their school
so i went to this school i went to that
school and i'm just enjoying all the
conversations because like oh i got my
mba i got my masters i got my phd on my
freaking this is all i'm the last one
this is sick
so what school did you go to i i didn't
go to college now come on pat what's
universal i'm telling you i never went
to college i had a 1.8 gp in high school
community colleges wouldn't accept me no
way you you're too smart to not come on
what college i say i'm telling you i
read 2 000 business books and i study
topics so if i chose a topic i bought 20
books on that topic and i read just that
topic that subject for two months then i
went to the next topic and the next
that's what i did
so some people who want to say the rich
people have these special you know gifts
and all this other stuff i'm sorry you
just don't want to read books you'd much
rather watch netflix so that argument is
i believe anybody can reach their
capacity
anybody has that shot but it takes so
much freaking work pain that not a lot
of people want to go through don't get
me wrong life happens to many different
people i'm hitting i'm not here to judge
but all i'm saying is the system of
capitalism sure the greatest system in
the world that allows a guy like me
who doesn't have nowhere in my life you
can pinpoint to say this guy was going
to win a lot not one thing you can
pinpoint nothing yeah
not one thing can pinpoint that's why i
believe in capitalism versus my family
believed in communism my family believed
in socialism now i'm like listen just
leave me alone let me see what i can do
if my mark is 50 i'm good i'm happy
because i'm giving my best if my market
pays 75 i'm happy because i'm giving my
best but if i keep bringing value to the
marketplace all of a sudden an
opportunity is going to come up yeah and
you can predict that opportunity all of
a sudden someone's going to say you know
what
um we're going to do this project i want
you to be a part of it here's how it's
going to work out freaking boom your
name pops what the hell just happened
here because behind closed doors rather
than throwing the towel you're giving
your best
capitalism works uh it's those who don't
work that hit capitalism unfortunately
you did a video
those who don't work and don't improve
some say i work my ass off but they
don't read books it's those two
criterias
you got to work you got to improve you
got to have a decent attitude if you
have that capital it's going to be
outlast
just the first two just the first two
the first two will land you a good job
you did a video that just came out on
valuetainment it was entitled they will
find you
yep right yep and
i think there's a
some symbolism right there a metaphor
for basically what you're saying and you
saw in the comments because sometimes
you'll read the comments when i'm
feeling
uh like uh
some s m vibes um
and they were like uh
pat you're the anomaly you're lucky hell
yeah pat you're the man great to go pat
you got lucky i can't do it i've been
working my ass out fine how do you
grapple with that because you are the
anomaly but that's because you though
because you worked your ass off that's
not true though listen nothing about
what i said has to do with my last name
nothing would what i said has to do with
the school i went to nothing with what i
said has to do with certain
you know
god-given nothing with what i said has
to do with that formula is very
transferable to others i don't jump 46
inches my name is not lebron james and i
jump 46 inches i'm not that guy okay
i'm not a
statistician i can just go through some
of the stuff that stuff and i'm ready no
i'm not that guy it's called work your
ass off
okay
and improve
work your ass off i challenge anybody
to do the following
take four subjects
sales negotiation human nature okay
sales negotiation human nature and money
go to amazon i will fund this if
somebody wants to do this
you do it you come back to me nothing
changed i'll fund the whole cost that
you had here
four topics read every book on
negotiation above 400 reviews on amazon
that's four four plus star read any book
that's about four star 25 of them 400
reviews on sales
read any book on human nature psychology
persuasion negotiation any of that stuff
force that like how to win friends
flying you know all that stuff then read
any book on money with 400 plus reviews
read principles like things like that by
dalio by buffett
and for two years obsess over doing that
for two years obsess over doing that two
years later work your ass off and
improve in a marketplace figure out a
way to improve your attitude sometimes
half the battle is people have some
shitty negative unattractive attitudes
they're a crap magnet everything is
shitty everything is complaining
everything is somebody else's fault
nobody is turned on by somebody that
constantly blames somebody else nobody i
go on when i was single i'd go on dates
and i would talk to a girl my last boss
was a jerk my last boss was an [ __ ] i
said out of your last five bosses which
one of them were [ __ ] all of them
i'm like [ __ ] that's not the boss's
problem it's you it ain't no boss's
problem it's your attitude sucks within
an hour you saw the attitude right
you read those four topics two years
work your ass off come back to me two
years from now matter of fact you won't
even come back to me because you forgot
about it because you're killing the
marketplace the market rewards people
who outwork and out improve it's proven
this doesn't mean you're going to be a
millionaire in two years this doesn't
mean you're going to be a billionaire in
two years here's what it does mean too
your market value is increasing somebody
may offer you something special next two
years some opportunities come up you go
into a company how many guys you know
work at a company for 50 60 80 000
company starts growing next you know
they're making 100 150 200. next thing
you know they get shares behind closers
they're investing money into a 401k
retirement whatever then 10 years that a
company has an exit this guy gets a 6.8
million dollar check how the hell did
you do it
yeah i think that and you know how many
people have done this by the way
not not 10 000 you know not not a
hundred thousand millions have done this
what you're describing is what education
is before government got involved yeah
so i'm you're you're describing what
college was for hundreds of years you're
describing
you know this the socratic and and plato
platonian method of education there's no
child left behind thing is less about
educating people and that was bush did
this it's less about educating people
and it's do you show up on time and are
you obedient that's all we care about in
education anymore we don't actually care
about teaching anybody anything this is
why jeff bezos wants all of his
employees to go to college do you show
up on time are you obedient then you
will graduate then you will move on to
another school where you can as long as
you pay money and you show up on time
and you're obedient you'll get your
certificate that says i'm now allowed to
earn money when you're a hundred
thousand dollars in debt when you're a
hundred thousand dollars in debt it
makes you a lot easier to control in
that environment you can't go out and
take the risk that you took when you're
a hundred thousand dollars now that's
forty nine thousand dollars in that well
you're well you're also an alpha you're
a hunter there's a hunter-gatherer issue
here you know i and listen we got a show
coming up where there's a big
conversation between the difference
between a gangster and a racketeer yeah
and a gangster can be a racketeer but a
racketeer can't be a gangster that's the
debate i think hunters can be gatherers
i don't know if gatherers can be hunters
then thomas soul i think said it best i
don't disagree but i will tell you
something i will tell you something in
that part here's the other part you
ready okay
uh do you judge somebody by their
friends
i do yeah okay how do you judge a guy
who's got a girl how do you judge him or
a gal that's got a guy like let's just
say a girl married up or a guy married
up what do you what do you say about
that guy or that gal he must be
something about him i don't know he's
gonna be like you know what good for him
that's what i said legit you're a good
sales person good for you whatever you
did and you keep them because you know
how sometimes you know a woman marries
up but they can't keep the guy
and sometimes a man marries up but he
can't keep her the challenge is also
keeping it's not about a one year two
year three year thing we're very quick
to always blame the guy but it's both
people's jobs
it's about keeping anybody can get it
who hasn't gotten somebody but can you
keep them right that's the name of the
seinfeld anyone can take the reservation
but can you hold
the reservation true
philosophy you have to go to that angle
so going back to going back to it here's
what i would tell you going back to it
you know what i will say this is what i
will say if you're if you're a hunter
gatherer whatever you may be your hunter
your gatherer whoever you may be
it's your job if you're a gatherer to
team up with a hunter
and if you're a hunter it's your job to
find the right supporters
i'm not sitting here saying everybody is
the same are you kidding me no i'm not
saying everybody's an alpha not at all i
i think there are i don't i think there
are people that are not alpha that are
richer than alphas though because
there's a lot of alphas that have
terrible attitude that cannot coexist
around other people because they keep
getting in their own way i know a lot of
alphas they keep getting in their own
flipping way
sometimes an alpha may need to step back
and say look i get it
i can't win as a one i can't win as a
two but i'm gonna be the sickest
freaking alpha at number four number six
and i'm gonna crush it and gradually i
move up what is the whole purpose of
being number one is that other people
with personalities can coexist if your
ego is so big and you can't keep people
around you that says something about you
not you that says something about the
individual i can't keep you so so we're
on the same page i'm not disagreeing
with you but if you're a gatherer guess
what
if you're a person that's a supporter
and you read those four books those four
topics next two
years and then you come to an alpha and
you say you know what patrick i'll tell
you something what's that i read a book
and here's what it said in the book
i'm like [ __ ] i never thought about it
that way yeah it's here let me share
with you hey let me tell you i just read
an article who said this about we should
do this in the company i never thought
about that before
that's that's also now the alpha's like
damn i'm not that good without that guy
[ __ ] i better keep that guy around that
guy knows what the hell he's doing
because i don't know that kind of stuff
so there is a way to always provide
value in the market and the bigger the
bigger thing here is like college to
your point it's almost like an idiot
test at this point you're going to go
you're going to spend all this money
when all you need is is your phone and
an internet and you can read everything
it goes back to that good will hunting
thing where it's like what you know i'm
the idiot but you're the guy spending 30
000 a year when all you needed was a
library card at the public library right
it's the same thing now every it's all
on your phone you can get it you you can
pay pay a professor a thousand bucks for
his entire syllabus and do the work
yourself but there's not a lot of auto
dia decks out there they won't actually
do the work they won't do it so that's
the part the owners i prefer to put the
onus on me that's what i always like to
do i like to put the onus on me what
could i have done differently i can't
change you yeah but i can sit there and
say what could have done so this whole
thing about well screw the ridge screw
these guys screw those guys dude look
let me transition into the amazon story
because you brought it up and i think it
has a lot to do what we're talking about
real quick thomas seoul yeah because i
think you'll like this and this goes to
what they're saying you're rich you're
rich you're rich thomas soul has a great
quote great quote about it it's a simple
question he goes what percentage is
somebody else's money do you deserve
what percentage of somebody else's
earnings
do you deserve who's the actual selfish
one here you did nothing absolutely
nothing but because this person has more
than you you think you deserve some of
that like what type of narcissist are
you
that that
i did a video one time titled the
ugliest qualities okay
ugliest qualities one of them was a
person that constantly blames another
one is a person that's constantly
entitled another one's a person that's
constantly playing in the victim game
you got the manipulator you got the
divider these are all disgusting
qualities this guy like i'm allergic to
all of that stuff when a person has
those qualities you can't be around me
for too long you're going to hate me
if you have any of those qualities
you're not going to like being around my
presence
because i'm always going to say what
could you have done differently about
you're going to be like what could i
have done do you know what my mom and my
dad did dude i get it
i can say the same story he's got one of
the craziest father stories he's a
millionaire how did he do it what could
you do differently about it well you
know but it's not like that you don't
know what it is about okay they're not
this way you're right i don't know i'm
not even debating him you're right i
don't know what it is to be in that
situation i don't know any about that
stuff anyways let me go to this year
which is what you're saying to to put a
bone that is it's so freaking easy to
come up with an excuse
it's so much harder to look in the
mirror and be like dude
get it to [ __ ] gather like it's on
you at the end of the day and it's just
even easier when you have celebrities
and politicians and people that are
supposed to be our leaders being like
you know what you're right you're right
it is an evil system and the rich are
terrible
oh
they're edifying and codifying these
people that are having these moments of
vulnerability they're going to stand up
though people going to stand up people
have to start standing up right now and
i'm not talking about in an [ __ ] way
you don't need to be an [ __ ] to stand
up but people need to stand up and have
a little bit of a backbone can i be a
little bit of an [ __ ] no you can't
because it because then you don't
convert and then the mission isn't
converting because right now the biggest
battle that's going on right now is the
is the battle of converting who's going
to convert better
it's all about who's going to convert
better what's going to help you to
convert better being an [ __ ] doesn't
convert it just doesn't you can be the
smartest [ __ ] in the world you're not
going to convert nobody pat it's what
that's my problem with trump
what do you mean that's your problem
with trump he's not converting people i
i think he's i think he's the people
love him and they also hate him because
he's the biggest [ __ ] in the world
yeah i don't i don't the problem is that
he's not
getting the people on the fence to be
like all right i'm gonna go with the app
but he's a catalyst he's a catalyst
though and he's making people who would
have sat on the sidelines again in the
game no they didn't he just lost
so he lost
yeah you went to whole different angles
you can go there if you want to i don't
know i think of [ __ ] i think of trump
yeah and again people love him because
he's the [ __ ] half the country do you
have to kind of i get it yeah but he's
not converting enough no no it went but
but wait a minute wait a minute
this guy this guy beat hillary clinton
least like no no no you cannot ever bro
are you kidding me this guy beat
a person with one of the most ridiculous
qualified resumes to go in that
he he's a nobody to beat hillary clinton
donald trump he's never been in politics
even reagan was a governor before reagan
was the president of sag reagan had been
nobody's done what trump's done nobody
by the way you can't put one person pat
i agree with you yeah so that doesn't
mean he's not a freaking [ __ ] i don't
i don't debate that more votes
less votes than when he beat hillary
well a lot more people voted he's got a
lot more votes hey i think the angle to
take is the following here's what i will
tell you about trump's uh biggest
challenge you ready
unnecessary giving birth to unnecessary
enemies for what that ain't gonna stop
for what
why are you giving birth to unnecessary
enemies what's the motive there i
understand go straight like the way he
came up with his campaign we're having
people come across that are rapists that
are fully get it you wanted to have a
blast everybody talks about everybody
invites you to the brilliant strategies
like an aoc using his strategy brilliant
strategy
genius but he created unnecessary
enemies unnecessary enemies when the
topic of discussion takes place here in
florida
and i ask who do you want to see let's
just say it's the between desantis and
the republic and then
and trump some camp says trump some
camps say desantis those who say
desantis they say it's the same exact
policies as trump minus
the unnecessary i've said it before i'd
vote for desantis well you said trump
it's it's not i and me versus we and us
that was he he made two major mistakes
he uses i and me instead of we and us
yeah now that was his major major
mistake i alone can fix it he lost me
that i was like you're the guy you're
the you're you're you're the messiah
yeah
it's a the narcissist
you know when a democrat says give me
all your money and i'll change the
weather that that doesn't bother you
who said that that's essentially what
the green new deal is i don't know give
give us 90. i'm not a supporter of the
big agreement but i would i would so no
to that
i would tell you the flip side of it i
will tell you the flip side of it if if
there is the unnecessary enemies that
are out
to face what's going on today you need
such a strong guy
you need such a strong guy you cannot
have a lightweight guy that's going up
against what's going on today because
it's whoever whatever republican becomes
the president next
it's going to be one of the hardest
positions jobs they're going to destroy
this guy whoever the next they're going
to destroy him the next guy it's going
to be one of the toughest jobs to have
the next person do you think there will
be a fair election
uh honest to god even in the midterms
yeah do you think there will be a fair
election i don't think so because
historically this is this is part of
like when he said he says hey why don't
you become better at stealing again once
you become better at manipulating the
game no i don't think there is i think
that's part of uh but i don't think
that's anything new i think that's been
part of election for
240 cameras on it now i just think it's
a little bit more you need more
technology today you need a little bit
more advancement today you need a little
bit more creativity i don't think it's
going to be a fair election no i don't
think it is but i don't think they need
to use that as an excuse to lose i think
they need to be invented like like if
you're going up against patriots and
well they they're watching fine
okay then confuse the [ __ ] out of them
but they have a playbook i don't give a
[ __ ]
don't do the play that you're gonna do
confuse the hell out of them so it
doesn't matter what it is they have your
playbook you still gotta today i went to
the gym in the morning freaking guy man
e this guy pisses me off because i go in
when you think about drop set what do
you do
you do two plates then you go to plate
and 25 then you go to a plate this guy
does the opposite so i go and i'm like
okay so okay hey i want you to do this a
bench with a plate on each side 15 times
okay cool
every time i leave my entire body hurts
i'm crying i get in my car i sit there i
cry for like five minutes
i just don't want him to see i'd like to
get a camera on that
so i go and i'm like okay let's do this
15 times i'm like i don't know where
this guy's gonna go he's the most
unpredictable trainer i've ever had
you feel good good let's put some more
weight on it
five second break i'm like no you're
supposed to go he said no no just push
it push it push it and he doesn't say
push it eight times push it 15 times i
can't push it 15 times yes you can go so
i'm going 10. five more so i'm like
we're done right puts more weight go
this doesn't make any any sense but he's
shocking the body politicians have to be
doing stop shifting blame onto the other
people
you can do the 15. seriously it's
overwhelming
look in the mirror and make it happen
i'm just being a little baby right now
but i tell you man i feel amazing hey
what's this guys we're happy that you're
doing this every morning amazing so
amazon offers to pay college fees of 750
000 frontline u.s workers this is a
guardian story amazon is the latest big
u.s firm to offer education focused
perks to workers after walmart target
and kroger the company which is
investing 1.2 billion dollars in the
scheme by 2025 said it would cover the
cost of college tuition fees and
textbooks for u.s hourly staff after 90
days of employment for as long as they
remain as amazon at amazon amazon is now
the largest job creator in the us we
know that investing in free skills
training for our teams can have a huge
impact of hundreds of thousands of
families across the country in may
amazon said it would hire 750 000
workers across its warehouse and
delivery network in us and canada
company hired around 500 000 staff last
year thoughts on this i have an opinion
on this i'm curious to know what you
guys think about this yeah i think it
goes to show exactly what i was saying
before like amazon
you know the the idea uh behind becoming
like a factory worker was it was you
know a good job but it's an entry-level
job it's a job that you move up from and
you know even the we talked to vanessa
who was one of our producers here that
uh the amazon jobs you know they 17 an
hour and then you go up to 17 25 you
work your 12 hour shifts so if if the
idea for them i don't think that they
would out price their own labor the idea
of college or in theory a college
education or higher education is to make
you worth more in in the job marketplace
so amazon's not going to make itself uh
its own employees uh more expensive i
think this goes to show what they think
more than anything what bezos thinks of
modern education where you know he needs
more disciplined employees he needs
employees that are clocking in clocking
out listening they're being obedient i
think that our modern education system
doesn't breed thinkers and entrepreneurs
i think it breeds factory workers okay
and he wants them to work in the factory
you know well
look uh i don't have such a negative
twist on this i think it's impressive
that or whether it's pr whether it's
for the good of society whether they
want a more educated workplace whether
they want them to be obedient whatever
it is the amazons of the world the
targets of the world the walmarts of the
world the krogers the world
i think they see this is a net positive
for people educating them paying for
their school
they're not graduating with debt that's
that's pretty good yeah um
the question here we kind of brought
this up earlier is this this might
attract talent but will this
keep the talent i know you could take
the reservation but can you hold the
reservation so what's going to happen to
these people they work for them they go
to school
they become you know have get a degree
in whatever economics accountability is
going to be the challenge are they going
to are they going to stay with amazon
are they going to stay with walmart what
are you going to do it's a form of
accountability so in the military when
they give gi bills a lot of guys will be
like [ __ ] i'm not going to go to school
but
i have to take 12 units for me to get my
1200 a month right and guys would take
the 12 units and never show up but the
military would keep paying the check
because the requirement was the 12 units
not the grades i didn't give a [ __ ] what
your grades where they care the fact
that you just showed that you have 12
units so amazon's gonna have to figure
out a way to have an accountability
system i don't know what that's going to
look like
i don't know if they're going to require
a gpa passing or using it abusing it so
eventually someone's going to get pissed
and they're not paying much [ __ ]
they're not doing that but in reality
that guy wasn't kind of he was trying to
use it's going to end up backfiring on
these guys in the next two years let me
let me go to the next section yeah
here's the second part i think it's a
great idea the fact that they're doing
it awesome that's part of capitalism let
a company be willing to create a social
program for the people rather than
putting it on the taxpayers that don't
need to pay somebody else's problem so
amazon is saying look we'll take care of
the social program amazon becomes a
smaller government that's taking care of
the employees check phenomenal job third
the company across the street that hires
warehouse workers he's getting screwed
because he's going to have that tough
conversations with his employees and
they're going to come up to and say hey
amazon's offering me full full ride
scholarship if i go there and do that a
2.0 gpa no one ever give me a full ride
scholarship now i can go and say i got a
full ride scholarship from amazon kind
of sounds cool right to be able to say
that if you're wanting to give me the
scholarship i'll stick around as well
the guy's like dude i can't get they
just raise the minimum wage to 15 bucks
i can't afford to pay you twenty two
thousand dollars you for schooling that
means a thirty five thousand dollar your
employee officially become a fifty seven
thousand dollar i can't afford that i
just can't
unless johnny i love you you have no
idea how much i love working for you but
do it i'm gonna go get that job at
amazon so elimination of competition at
the highest level all right again
capitalism competitiveness fine
here's what i would do if i was amazon
though there's no way in the world i if
i'm amazon i'm sending my guys to other
universities no way i'm gonna start at
amazon university yeah i'm gonna go
recruit a thousand professors and
teachers from other universities giving
them 10 percent bonus on top of what
they're doing maybe a 20 bump if you're
getting 80 grand i'm going to give you
96. if you're making 60 i'm gonna give
you 72. if you make it a hund i'm going
to give you 120. come to amazon
university i would gradually start
recruiting the best professors away to
work for amazon university that would be
the strategy on what to do then from
there it is what it is because at this
point what are you going to be doing
these people are still going to go out
there so the challenge with that is are
you going to be able to pull
universities at all these different
places it's going to be tough because
it's physical it's not like they can
travel to a place to be at the
headquarters dude online university is
that what's going on so that's the kind
of challenge but i would do my own
universities
the devil's in the details too you're
right because maybe this is a military
type situation where you're not getting
it done when you're working at amazon
maybe you have to guarantee amazon eight
years to get them paid off or something
maybe it's like a 10-year if you're with
amazon for 10 years we're going to pay
it off i don't know the details of it
but i have a very very hard hard to
believe feeling like you're right i have
like you could go to pepperdine for 75
000 a year and uh
you know amazon's going to pay for that
or they're going to have like a
celebrity it has to be a system of
accountability go ahead kai pat also one
thing that i was that i was thinking
about was obviously um what's the one
thing that amazon has had a lot of
trouble with the last
times we've mentioned them in the
podcast obviously maintaining people
having them work there long enough
and not burning through people so high
turnover i quickly i quickly looked up
what is the
average tenure for somebody at a
fulfillment center want to make any
guesses hmm one year oh was it that long
how long one year
they were saying that that was that was
it so if you're looking at 90 days
that's what three months of just before
you can even be eligible at that point
it's a competitive advantage of keeping
them
staying there longer than a year because
college is what three
three to four years so if you can if
they can bump up that rate then
obviously you're paying pennies for
pennies on the dollar to keep people
working because
uh training someone in the hiring
process is what often costs a lot of
money so if you can avoid that that
money's made up on the back end and
that's another great point kai just made
three to four years college it's really
four to five if you're going full time
now so if you're working full time in
amazon college might take you six seven
years yeah okay you don't want to turn
that off i don't know if you did or not
they're not letting you go is what
you're saying you're gonna be there for
a while i just don't think jeff bezos is
the most altruistic human being on earth
there's i i see an ulterior motive he's
better than stalin though i don't i
don't know stalin was better than him
apparently
i don't i don't know if i even go there
because like let's just say i think he's
so logical that he's like this is going
to cost us a couple billion dollars
screw it we'll write it off and we'll
use it as marketing cost and marketing
and instead of advertising we're going
to use this it's fine we can afford it i
think he's so logical
that uh like even the guy the guy never
got the gift of gab
he comes off after of going to space
comes back and says i just want to thank
all the employees for funding this you
paid for all of this it's like okay if
there's a million different ways toward
it that was definitely the one way you
shouldn't avoid it but it is what it is
but don't fire that speech right
it's walmart it's kroger it's target all
these major
warehouse type factory companies that
are employing
ridiculous amounts of americans are
following suit right so there's
something that's great i think it's
great what i'm trying to tell you is i
think that's great because anytime
capitalists create social programs
that minim that lowers taxes because the
capitalist is taking the job off of that
and they're doing it themselves if you
left it alone this would have happened
by itself anyways if we had a flat tax
imagine if we had a flat tax okay
flat tax 10 percent
if we had a 10 flat tax we give that to
the government let's just say for
military
and everybody else keeps another 15
what the hell do you think banks would
do with that or these companies would do
it you think they're just going to sit
on the cash
no it would be so competitive that
people would be forced to have
universities child care day care you
know all these other actors would be
amazing if there was what happened steve
forbes ran a lot
but 1996. in america still believe that
government employees politicians
use money better than people in private
business too so it is what it is they
trust politicians with no experience in
business to spend your money better than
the people that actually rent business
that do it on a daily basis
it's it's fascinating
my education reform i did i got me
kicked out of uh a brainstorm meeting
with christy there there was a big
problem with this thing called abbott
districts in new jersey where uh
low-income high-risk schools get an
insane amount of money but it's really
just a slush fund it's just like so you
know a a general contractor will donate
you know 10 million dollars to a
campaign and then oh well newark shabazz
school needs a new pool it's 30 million
dollars who gets the contract the
contractor right the pool doesn't even
get filled up because there's an
insurance issue there's a giant pool in
newark shabazz that doesn't even work
right it's a long story the average
student in in new jersey when i was
there was like 17 000 a year and abbott
districts uh were like 36 000 per
student and they were like okay let's
brainstorm our ideas like how can we do
education reform you know bring the cost
down but not hurt the students because
the whole point of the abbott district
was it was supposed to help these these
students but after like 30 years of
twice the money the graduation rates had
actually dropped in the high risk areas
trenton camden newark right so they're
going back and forth do this do that and
i literally just said why don't you just
give the money to the kids
if you graduate you get twenty thousand
dollars that's it give give give the
money and i got laughed out of the room
i was like what it's a scholarship give
it to him in a scholarship yeah give him
if you're gonna spend this money on the
kids give it to him it'll circulate back
in the economy they won't know what to
do with them like i feel like the way to
incentivize these guys they're making
more money on the show just so you know
i wouldn't do it the way amazon's doing
it my mind wouldn't be the way they're
doing it the way i would be doing it
would be a tier system here's what my
tier system would be you come back with
your grades based on the gpa that you
keep and maintain it will be a tier
system you may make more than others do
i may pay you more
than what your minimum was so if a
person is doing better at a university
with better grades i'm going to pay you
maybe five thousand dollars more per
year than the other person that's not
i'm not going to do it this way you
first get the results then you get the
meritocracy
and then you get the results that's an
accountability nightmare like you just
get the money then you get the power and
then you get the education when you were
a kid i'm sure you guys did it too if
you got an a your dad gave you five
bucks if you got a b your dad gave you
one dollar if you got to see your dad
gave you a whooping like that's that's
the way it was can we give janet yellen
some love here i've been with jenna's
been waiting let's let's give janet the
ill and someone janet yellen love learns
of a possible october default on u.s
debt swollen
by the pandemic this is a new york times
story the united states could default on
its debt sometime in october if congress
does not take action to raise or suspend
the debt limit treasury secretary janet
dillon warned on wednesday the
extraordinary measures
that the treasury department has been
employing to finance the government on a
temporary basis since august first will
be exhausted next month
yellen said in a letter to lawmakers
once all available measures and cash on
hand are fully exhausted the united
states of america would be unable to
meet its obligations for the first time
in our history i like that
yellen said that a default would cause
irreparable harm to the u.s economy and
to global financial markets and that
even coming close to defaulting could be
harmful
maybe that's not a bad idea for us to
actually see how fake of an economy we
have maybe let's find out for about 30
days how fake our economy is maybe let's
find out what's really going on let's
listen this is coming from a guy i just
bought a big house can you imagine my
property value drops 25 percent if
that's the number fine do it
let's find out how fake the current
economy earned it down let's not do that
no no no but wait a minute why not how
long can we manage fake you realize
we're funding this fake
we're funding all this fakeness
we're funding all of this fakeness
interest rates staying low for as long
as they have first time in the history
of america it's funding fake economy in
the words of richard nixon they're all
kenzians now there is nothing good about
what they're doing right now it's just
temporary catastrophe because they're
worried about whether they're going to
get reelected or not and by the way
that's not a left or right thing that's
both of them
neither one of them wants the economy to
get back to being real because that
president will be a one-term president
but american voters have to be thinking
about what's more important a fake
economy that eventually the whole thing
explodes or let's kind of settle down a
little bit let me ask you pat every year
there's this like raise the debt ceiling
we're gonna default like every every
year every year it happens
what's different this time around
is there something different obviously
with the printing of money five trillion
over the last two years
is it different is it the same oh my god
this guy's falling
through at the last second the superhero
comes in and saves it they need it
what's different
what's different is they
they they want to pass a three and a
half million dollar budget by september
27th you want to ask that let me go to
page go to page 8's uh joe manchin you
brought this up let's just read what joe
has to say about this so let's see joe
manchin says there's no way to pass a
three and a half billion dollar budget
trillion dollar budget bill by september
27th cnbc story notice what she said
she said what by the end of the month is
what she said right by the end of the
month we have to figure out a way to
address this by the end of the month
right exhaust it next month so now joe
says
no way we're going to pass this 3.5
trillion dollars
adding that there's no way to meet the
september 27 deadline set by democrats
mansions comments come as lawmakers work
to approve the measures which would
invest in climate policy and expand
social programs including child care and
health care without the support of
republicans who have opposed the
proposed tax increases to fund it we've
already put out 5.4 trillion dollars and
we've tried to help americans in every
possible way we can and a lot of help
that we've put out there is still there
and it's still going to run clear until
next year 2022 so what's the urgency
what's the urgency that we have it's not
the same urgency that we had with the
american rescue plan he said this is
mentioned saying this so the you asked
the question mansion just answered it
for you
they're trying to push to get that three
and a half trillion dollars
look look at what they've done look at
what they've done they shut your
business down they bankrupted you for 18
months now they're going to raise your
taxes higher than they've ever raised
them until everybody in america is
paying 50 of their freaking money to
things that they don't want and they're
devaluing the dollars that you already
have
so not only did they shut you down and
give all your money to their donors but
now they're gonna raise your taxes so
what little hope you have left
disappears and your money save that
money is going to be halved what is the
value of the dollar in 10 years
this is insane what we're doing is pure
insanity this is like
this is a theft the likes of which this
is a wealth transfer likes with we've
never seen in our lifetime
like i can't even believe people are
going along with this
like think of those three things these
are incontrovertible facts again this is
not left this is not right this is
reality both sides are doing it they
shut you down it's not a left or right
they devalued your dollar and now
they're stealing your future earnings
but it's but it's it's guys there's
nothing worse than fake success because
the fall is
unbelievably
painful
you know what's fake success like you
know how the boxer you know the scene
where where rocky is like
you know when mickey says you know you
dude this guy's going to hurt you when
he's facing against who the the clever
lank right like this guy's going to do
this you're not at this guy so what are
you talking about i can beat him he says
no
you can't you're not ready for it
because sometimes behind like boxers
what do they do they only put people in
front of their boxer because they're
trying to build the guy's confidence but
the trainer kind of knows this guy
cannot fight with the number one number
two or number three you ain't that good
i'm just trying to protect you right to
kind of get a test for it
we've been faking it as if america's
economy is bulletproof it's not
it's not they have to kind of bring you
back and realize like do you realize how
many things that are common sense we're
starting to question whether we're right
or wrong
let me say that one more time how many
things that are common sense what's
common sense
they don't go into debt more than you
can afford but we're like no but we
should because that's what we're
supposed to do
uh let's keep printing money and it's
gonna
decrease the value of u.s dollar not
necessarily
not necessarily because people say it's
not going to
tell me a time in history that anything
you over printed the value of that one
up tell me show your work one time but
but the point is we
as the populace
are questioning ourselves like the whole
gaslighting deal we're getting destroyed
with gas lighting right now you're
starting to question like normal things
am i really that dumb
am i like maybe i'm not as smart as
these guys at this level maybe yelling
is at a whole different level than i am
maybe i don't have the intelligence of
what these guys are maybe i should just
shut up and say well these guys know
what they're doing and i don't you're
right let's keep printing money you're
right let's keep doing this you're right
let's keep doing that
no i think i think common sense people
need to go back to common sense
this is not taking you know
technical math this is common sense math
it's not it's not extremely technical if
you keep printing anything the value
goes down period it just does and they
keep doing it anyways so what do you
think they should actually do zero
should they is there is there a number
that they should
come up with is it one trillion what did
you ever quit that you were cold turkey
what did you ever quit that you were
cold turkey on did you ever put anything
cold turkey like you're like
i was smoking weed and then all of a
sudden next i'm like i'm done chew in
the bag i was drinking alcohol the next
acid i'm done drinking alcohol luckily
i've never had those problems but i know
you stopped drinking hard liquor yeah
but you in the background went cold
turkey yeah you do cold how did you do
alcohol wait a minute like did you go
cold turkey with alcohol hard alcohol
yeah yeah yeah but i still like i i used
to drink a lot now i'm down to like you
know a couple beers on on a friday
that's pretty much okay but that's not
cold turkey though no no i'm talking the
only thing i ever did cold turkey was
chew in the bag okay so the point i'm
trying to make to you is you don't have
to go cold turkey with this you don't
have to go from one percent to six
percent
no you put a plan and you manage
expectation every quarter the interest
rates are going up a quarter of a
percent the next four years
i just want people to realize so guess
what you do if you say every quarter the
rates are going up a quarter of a
percent the populace is sitting there
saying what fine it's good because it's
getting me to be prepared that in the
next four years i can't be going around
thinking i'm big shouting anything no
this is kind of what it's looking like
every quarter every quarter we're going
through this every quarter we're going
through this
rather than this
yeah we still can't i know we still
can't we still can't manage expectations
so should we change the election cycles
then instead of two
four year terms should the president be
a one eight year term should we get rid
of reelections the only way to do that
is with foresight i mean so much of what
we're doing now is dependent on election
cycles and and i think that that's you
know what kind of i'm not a fan of the
elections i'm not i'm not or term limits
i i think a little bit more realistic
than election voting is supposed to be
term limits i mean we're we are supposed
to be the term limits you know so
sometimes look you could put you know
but the federal anybody where pelosi is
they're going to what the federal
reserve
is its own standalone
so to me federal it's not even a
government agency i know it's not the
federal reserve needs to be standalone
and make its own here's what we're doing
over the next eight years so the voter
like let's just say
if the president's running and the
president says the following says listen
guys i don't control federal reserve
that's not my job so whatever happened
with the interest rates i know it kind
of affected the market i can't change
that because it's out of my jurisdiction
the federal reserve has one job in place
is to make sure we become as close to as
debt-free as possible and it maintains
the economy in a proper way that keeps
growing right and healthy employment as
well yeah employment as well so so i
think if they set that part aside to say
that this is its own person that gets
voted by the by the people you know
somebody that we even elect for federal
because it's a big this big decision
maker maybe even more powerful than a
president sometimes right so if we did
that and a person said
yeah president biden president trump you
don't have any
jurisdiction over me on what we do here
you can give feedback but this is what
we're doing the interest rate is going
to go up a quarter of a percent
every quarter over the next eight years
and we're gonna try to hover around
three percent what i've picked a number
i'm just making up a number there for
you but staying the way we are right one
more month
one more quarter yeah one more question
this is not an effective thing at zero
we can't maintain no way no way but i do
want to i don't know why is that
important by the way why is it so
important to get them to a normal level
how do you pay off debt in your personal
life
do you do you all of a sudden you mean
you just raise your debt ceiling you
can't do that though you can't do that
do you understand what you just said
like it's a joke but you can't do that
right hey can we raise my credit card
limit i'm in debt forty thousand like if
you call actually think about it you
gotta you got you got a credit card with
ten thousand dollars you're at ten
thousand dollars you call mbna you call
amex you call this government say hey i
know i'm in that ten thousand dollars my
credit card limit is ten thousand
do you guys mind to help my credit score
increase my limit to twenty thousand
dollars because it's hurting my credit
score yeah you tell me what discover
amex or visa mastercard is gonna tell
you they're gonna say
i'm sorry what somebody should actually
do this and say but presidents do that
why can't i do that
that's raising the the maximum capacity
of the debt i'm talking about you're
talking about raising the interest rates
from zero to point two five yeah to 100
points or whatever it is but why is it
in one direction why is it important
to raise
if your basement is flooded it doesn't
matter how many additions you put onto
the house the basement's still flooded
that's what he's saying no matter how
many times you you address the the debt
right you're not addressing the deficit
you you you have to get rid of the water
that's flooding your basement putting an
addition on the house doesn't do that
i'm 1000 with you on the on why you
don't want debt in your life i'm with
you but why is raising the interest
rates
important meaning why do you want to get
to three percent yeah as an example look
when the i understand that concept about
not having debt i get it in terms of the
interest rate when the interest rates
are low
anything that you finance the value of
it is higher because it's free money
right like right now everybody who's a
businessman who's running a company if
they can get a line from the government
for billion dollar debt go get it
everyone's doing it leverage through
this if you can get 100 same thing at
one percent it's nothing you paying
nothing there's one thing you do
percentage money is so cheap today go
get it so this is why you can qualify
you know how you see certainly the rich
can qualify right people that are buying
one house two house three house four
house five hours six on seven eight nine
dude
you got six ferraris in a garage got
nine lime i remember a guy back in 2005.
he had four different rolls-royce same
exact phantom parked outside of his
house everybody would just go go to this
guy said look this guy's freaking
rich as hell but no income no asset
anything you can finance for nothing
the moment 08 came around the market
tanked 38 percent not only did he lose
all his uh rolls royce he lost the two
houses he owed the government five
million dollars and he didn't know how
to pay for it but that needed to be
filtered out of course so the interest
rates makes everything eventually be
worth what it's worth a guy buys a house
right down here i looked at this house
we went and looked at it
we walked left the house it looked like
a 50 shades of grey house the guy ends
up buying it for 17 million
the next month after he buys it for 17
million dollars he puts it on the market
for 31 million dollars he just raised
the price to 32 million dollars
someone's about to buy that thing for 30
million
in four months he bought it from 17
million it's going to sell it for 30
million
that doesn't make any sense
good purchase right there he didn't do
nothing to the house the house like
nothing to the house here's ultimately
my question and i want to get your
advice on this you remember back in the
80s um
interest rates on mortgages were like 12
yeah let me say that again interest
rates on mortgages were like twelve
percent the great jimmy carter
everything was going insane well even
when reagan was there it it was all
throughout the 80s he lowered it it
started to lower it sort of taper off
but even in all even up until the 90s it
was at double digits almost the point is
this comes from the community
reinvestment i said up until the 90s all
throughout the 80s but the point is this
what's the sweet spot you're saying use
three percent as an example
obviously zero is no good and obviously
you don't want to be spending 10 on your
mortgage payment on your interest on
your is there a number that you have in
mind is what i'm asking you said
no man like i mean it's like asking how
much brake do you need it's like well if
you're going 25 miles an hour you need
this much brake if you're going 95 miles
an hour you need a little more brake you
know
i mean it it's it's subject to the times
double digit wasn't in the 90s it was
84. i said into through the 80s up until
90. but then carter's last era was last
year was 16.39 crazy and we got elected
it was 5.54 so he took it from five
prime rate
he took he took the average yield from
five point five four to sixteen percent
see these were paying 14 15 16 at the
time by the way everything leds were
paying 16 yeah that's what i'm saying
it's insane but every the conversation
they're having right now
this is the type of stuff that they
don't teach you in school this is what i
talk about all the time but
you talked about getting books getting
books on negotiations getting books on
sales getting big books on how money
works interest rates is our major part
of it i think you're not i think what
you're teaching is necessary i think
that concept is necessary but even this
is stuff that that this is
macroeconomics
but it's not though just go to that
visual just think about
like i said what's tall you said i don't
think six is tall six times i said why
do you think that because any
everything's always i'm not good enough
we always have that mentality i'm not
rich enough i'm not successful i'm not
tall enough i'm not strong enough it's
always the guy that's a little bit more
stronger that's strong right we're
always kind of think that way and then
internally we're confident but i don't
know maybe about this
it's not if you called your credit card
company
and you said i got ten thousand dollar
credit card with ten thousand i max it
out can you give me another limit for
ten grand what's the credit card company
gonna say to you
actually tell me what you think they're
going to say to you
they're going to say
what the hell is wrong with you
credit card companies will probably say
sure buddy keep charging you will not do
that no to give you additional 10.
you give an additional 10 to somebody
that doesn't know how to handle their
money you don't do that you know when
you know what might have given you
another 10. you know what points you
know when i got you know when i got a
ton of credit
is is when i don't need any credit yeah
exactly we're going to raise your limit
to 100 000. cool
but you have to spend ten thousand
dollars a month yeah but but the point
i'm trying to make to use this stuff is
not as complicated what the politicians
are famous for doing is to convince the
populace that they're smarter than them
and let them make the decision for them
no no these are regular people just like
you okay these are regular people they
just decided to go get their job to be a
politician and they're on tv and just
because you're on tv people think you're
smart because you don't agree with you
that we need to stop glorifying
politicians left and right if i could
for a second all right because we we
kind of brushed over this but i think
this is very important for people to
hear
they're they're trying they are
basically with this re infrastructure
act trying to make an effective 50 tax
rate for all americans essentially is
what they're going for okay
so just understand people listening at
home okay especially my blue collar
people you're sitting in traffic an hour
to get to work you don't get paid for
that all right then you're going to go
to work half of you work a job you don't
want to work in but you need to because
you're you're you you have
responsibilities and you're a dutiful
person so eight hours of your day you do
that then you sit in traffic another
hour home ten hours of your day then you
see your family for three hours you go
to sleep okay so ten hours away from
your family doing a job you probably
don't want to do sit in a traffic you
don't want to sit in under this you've
got to understand what taxes are that
means you will not earn a dollar you
will not actually earn any money for you
or your family not january not february
not march not april not may not june
until july first you are a wage slave to
the government to the government that
just left 85 billion dollars worth of
stuff behind in for the taliban that's
how much they care about the hours of
your life that's how much they care
about your money your tax dollars that
they're gonna raise that they just left
85 billion dollars for the taliban to
use as as christmas toys okay and now
they want more of your life stop looking
at it as money folks i beg you stop
looking at it as money this is hours of
your life that they are stealing from
you yeah i mean that's uh
that brings it back to very uh good
visual for people to be thinking about
so let's go to page number seven college
students chant f joe biden at football
games okay is this a good thing this is
a bad thing
so page seven
uh college football fans have taken to
chanting f joe biden in the stands this
is a
during games
and saturday marked the second straight
weekend of presidential taunts old rose
sports identified at least four
instances of the chance f joe biden at
college games
during the weekend of september 4 2021
the chance broke out at coastal carolina
university virginia tech auburn
university and texas a m the chat bro uh
chat chant broke out again
amid the student section of the auburn
alabama state game on september 11
donald trump jr predicted that this
trend will continue he said the biden
presidency has gotten so bad that the
media can't run
cover for him anymore even at this last
week's 9 11 event that took place do you
know barack obama spoke do you know joe
biden spoke i'm sorry do you know what
uh
uh president bush spoke you know who
didn't speak this week talk about it joe
biden speak didn't speak this week and
they say it's one of two reasons
republicans are saying he didn't speak
because
uh uh
everybody was gonna boom and he was
gonna get destroyed like he you know
the fact that their team doesn't want to
say anything even democrats are saying
they just thought it wouldn't be a good
look for him to talk right now it's
better off for him to just kind of take
it easy but what do you think about
these chants chant chanting your
president f joe biden is this a good
thing is this a bad look what do you
think and i'm gonna remove my uh any
biases whatsoever but the same [ __ ] was
happening at different places regarding
donald trump two years ago yeah so
lebron called him a chump okay so like
let's stop making this a big i'm not
saying we are but
cool drunk college kids in the south are
screaming or f joe biden cool
liberals in in boston were doing the
same thing for trump this is such a
non-story for me it's the same thing
that happened a few years ago is it a
good thing though
or is it irrelevant it's like freedom of
speech do it if you want to do it go for
it gives a [ __ ] okay
drunk college kids in the south at a
football game you have a strong
different opinion look man i think uh i
think what you're seeing again is the
stratification of look when you have xi
jing biden get on uh air on thursday and
threaten the entire
country he gets on and he threatens uh
duly elected fairly elected governors if
you won't do what i say and if you won't
subject that subjugates your citizens in
the way i demand i will get you out of
the way my patience is wearing thin this
isn't about your freedom you know what
double barrel two of these to uh to you
uh xi jing biden and and i'm saying this
as a guy that hated george bush i know
everybody thinks i'm like a right wing
guy on this but like i hated george bush
to me george bush was the second worst
president of all time behind buchanan
buchanan is the worst president of all
time by far all right he let the country
fall apart he basically gave up in his
uh in his term he was like screw it i
don't want to deal with this and he let
the country rip in half thank god for
abraham lincoln following him okay then
bush inherits a surplus
and turns it into a deficit and gets us
into a war that costs us 300 million
dollars a day george bush inherited a
surplus people don't want to give uh
clinton credit he we left us with a
surplus okay
we're talking about janet yellen ray's
we had a surplus in our lifetime like
it's like we act like this is insane by
the way
i became i guess a fan of democrats i
thought clinton was a g and and i was a
fan
bush was objectively horrible and the
fact that bush speaks at 9 11 doesn't
sit with me very well either to be
honest with you but
you can't say that pat is a big fan of
george bush
god bless you they write letters to each
other
pat would probably have a different
opinion george bush needs to know you
did meet george w bush you are you
didn't think he was a great guy but
listen this is this is not this is not
about whether
i get along with anybody i agree or
disagree with for the most part i get
along with anybody it doesn't matter i
sit down i can talk to anybody no this
isn't about that this is about
is this a good idea for this to be
taking place for me it tells me a couple
different things i've never liked it
never liked it to get to that point
never to make that be okay i was so
furious when uh what's his name said uh
hey chump he wasn't gonna come anyways
no when he said hey chump he wasn't
gonna come anyways and lebron called the
president hey chump and duran said i'm
not going to the white house and then
steven a smith and max kellerman went
back and forth and will kane disagreed
with both of them wilkin ended up
getting fired now he's got a job at fox
news anyways
i'm not a fan of what's going on here
but what it does tell you is the
following wait because it's
disrespectful or
will kane said uh uh you know you should
respect the office yeah but these guys
are like wow you know
anyways here's here's where i go with
this what i go with this is demographics
marketing it tells you who the nba fan
is uh who the audience is it tells you
what college football is college
football is a conservative fan base if
that's what they're saying well in the
south pad is that these are by the way
these are not small markets you're not
going to texas i'm sorry you're not
talking about cities
virginia tech is not a republican
university buddy virginia take your sin
as a republican university no i'm just
saying it's in the south auburn
university coastal carolina oh it's in
the south
it doesn't matter it's not l.a you're
saying drunk
a university in the south automatically
everybody's going to be categorized
are we not aware of uh the south usually
votes republican you're a smart guy you
know this already university is
different because university people
don't go to university from the city
there and people come from all across
the country so it's not like
yeah asheville but every city in the
south is all i'm saying
all i'm saying to you is it's
the audience that's doing it
it's interesting that's all i'm saying
the audience that's doing it is
interesting i've never been a fan i
don't care if it's joe trump i don't
think i know we got a wrap up here i
want to get your we can obviously do
monday morning quarterback next time
something we've been talking about for
over a year now the gavin newsom recall
is today yep do you have any strong
feelings or or
prognostications on this there's a lot
of things you're hearing from both sides
the one side is saying there's no way
it's going to happen obama pelosi
everybody showed up to save news from
everybody's commenting on the other side
larry elder california has five million
more democrats than republicans you need
to know the stats on that as well uh in
the recall side a bunch of republicans
that were going and voting they said you
already voted like i didn't vote and so
this lady's asking you know five other
ladies that were in the voting place did
you guys you know said i voted but i
didn't vote are you democrat we're
probably we're done we're republican
wait a minute your republicans said the
machine that you already voted yeah but
we didn't vote
you know again going back to some of the
stuff that's taken place there you think
they're gonna let newsom
well two times this has happened in the
history of america i think one of them
is davis and the other one is some some
i don't know who the other person maybe
we have uh governor
meet kevin paffrath on again
him and gerard might go to lunch i think
him and gerard need to do podcasting
we'll do a podcast right outside of one
of his super happy fun time
concentration camps i think he's
necessary for california fyi the real
quick i know you got to leave you
actually asked an incredible question
yesterday if tupac was alive today yeah
50th 50th birthday birthday was
yesterday right yeah that's it do you
where do you think tupac would stand
today in today's i think he was very i
think he'd be one of the biggest voices
in america i think he'd be one of the
biggest voices but he would either be an
aoc type of person because he could be
an aoc type of person you know i i i see
that depends if he made a lot of wealth
he may be a jay-z type of person i just
don't think for two pounds you would
definitely be a blm type of person
definitely yeah 100 percent out of that
i think he'd be very blm and i think
he'd be very very aoc until this moment
he's so anti-authority and he is so
anti-establishment i think this last
would have kind
he also said a lot of stuff about his
own side so he wasn't one that was
afraid to push back on his own community
he was not one that he would be a very
interesting person well there is a
chance
the song he wrote about uh hit him up
not hit him up the side has got a baby
he's got a baby again that's talking
about the community yeah anyways
there is a chance he's still alive i
gotta go i gotta go i got money for war
are we doing this thursday thursday
we're doing this again and thursday
we're having a special guest chas paul
palman terry from bronx taylor is going
to be here this thursday on the podcast
amazing make sure you put that as a
reminder same time again this thursday
which has parliamentary to talk more
about his life his story as well as
mafia states of america
if you enjoyed the podcast thumbs up and
give us a subscribe we're about to get
to a hundred thousand take everybody bye
bye bye bye
nice
you